[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or is that free to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
that where two guys Hank and John Green
who are brothers we answer your
questions give you devious advice and
bring you all the week's cuse from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey John how are
you well Hank I'm just back from a long
bike ride and I seem to have injured
myself in my the seat area I would say
broadly speaking as sort of my guess
what I guess I I guess if it were in my
privates if you will I like the idea
that that the seat is a part of the body
that is the part of the body that sits
on the seat so you put your seat on the
scene the whole everything that touches
the seat is the seat that is my theory
and that whole part hurts so I'm just
trying to just trying to work through
the component too much Hank Hank Hank
Hank Hank what do you remember in our
last episode or maybe a couple episodes
ago I don't know when it happened oh do
you remember that you said that you were
going to burn all the copies of a book
Oh God that yeah because it talked about
how Python ha lay eggs and of course you
knew this type of eggs because they they
gave live birth well Hank we got really
for the first time corrections to a
mistake you made it so rare on dear Hank
and John oh boy I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna highlight one out of many because
it turns out you could have just googled
this there's tons of pictures of it this
one comes from Ishmael who writes Dear
John and Hank I could not help but
notice a glaring error and here the
beginning of the latest episode
proximately two minutes into the episode
Hank describes a passage from a
children's book that mentions a mother
Python in her hatchway yep we've been
yep ha and Hank says pythons is live
birth and don't have hatchlings that's
incorrect
pythons do indeed lay eggs it's almost
like Hank should trust what's in books
instead of what's in his mind that
wasn't from Ishmael that was from me
it's true it's true boas give rise first
okay
we're talking about those I know I'm
aware I'm aware that's just I'm
explaining how I got confused all right
all right well I am delighted I am
absent a delighted by this situate
frankly I hey we I well the only reason
it hurts so bad is that I spent so much
time whining about it oh yeah yeah oh I
know
so just never never whine I guess is the
solution to that problem yeah thanks for
starting with that joke my pleasure did
you did you not have a PO I do I have a
haiku by Kobayashi Lisa okay hit me
everything I touch with tenderness alas
pricks like a bramble
dang that's hard out there
sorry doubt therefore a Kobayashi Issa
and other haiku writers love suffering
man yeah a disappointment when you try
for the tender touches Hank sometimes
you find that that just comes with a
bramble yeah I tried to tenderly touch
Python live birth Python babies but it
just hit that hard eggshell that's my
that's my poem for the day I Hank I'm
really excited to get to the questions
from our listeners we got some great
questions this week and this is my
favorite one okay so can we start there
mm-hmm all right we've also got some
great sign offs this week some great
name specific sign offs this question
comes from April who writes Dear John an
egg I deliver babies for a living as you
probably know from experience human
babies are wonderful and amazing but not
always cute this is especially true in
the beginning when they're purple and
wrinkly I know it gets better but
sometimes new parents are a little
shocked by their offsprings appearance
my dutch mom has a saying for this
problem which basically translates as
ugly in the cradle but pretty at the
table is there some catchy phrase like
this in English that I can use with new
parents showers and the crew this month
April
oh good sign-off I okay first of all
when you say I deliver babies for a
living that really sounds like you put
them in a truck and family that is my
assumption how else would you deliver
them you're delivering
to someone from somewhere to something
it's really you deliver a baby from one
end of a person to the other end is the
most of the delivering that happens I
mean my kids listen to this podcast I'd
like you to be as vague as possible okay
that's that's just that's it that's the
sitch yet John what were you were you
surprised by the way that your baby
looked when it was uh when it was first
I mean look Hank this is a podcast
that's going to be publicly listened to
but also that potentially my own
children were one day or so they were
both beautiful and amazing and they
looked like actual gods like tiny chairs
they looked like they'd been painted by
Michelangelo I was astonished by their
beauty okay
samesies yeah but with like a cherub
painted by Michelangelo except with the
head of an almond this is just oh man
I'm sure Michelangelo never painted a
chair but I'm gonna get in a lot of
trouble for that oh we definitely I
definitely didn't have any of the people
there were lots of lovely people around
and none of them said to me don't worry
he'll look better tomorrow April yeah
yeah then you're saying like so just so
you know I'm aware of how ugly this
thing is you know what I say that maybe
they aren't thinking that their baby is
super ugly but but I if they do look to
be in distress if they're asking
questions like is it supposed to look
like that yeah yeah give them some
security and the fact that their baby is
is normal but you know and sometimes
they're not pretty at the table let's be
honest I think the first words that
every baby should hear upon birth are
ugly at the cradle but pretty at the
table like after after someone's gone
through all of that effort to give birth
I think it's really good if the very
first thing that you hear about your
baby ugly oh wow yeah I absolutely agree
you just give reassurance so if people
are like wow is my baby is my baby ugly
you can just be like no it looks like a
regular baby you could just say what
Hank said the
first time he met his nephew Henry well
it's a baby yep yep that's what that is
this next question comes from Jamie and
we need to get to it so I'm gonna have
it be the second question because I got
I got this thing that I'm shaking at my
microphone right now because I was so
entranced by this question and by my
inability to have had it previously
Jamie asks dear Hank and John I come to
you with an urgent matter I can't sleep
at night without knowing how our hot dog
buns pre-cut if they're stuck together
in the package who went and bought some
hot dog buns John yeah and I haven't
opened them and I had never thought
about this but it's true so they clearly
like like there's a machine that just
like lays out the buns like four at a
time but they when they get cooked they
bake together so that they're like this
isn't the case for every hot dog buns
but if you get the cheap ones it's like
this so that we bake together and and
there's all stuck together and you have
to pull them apart but when you pull
them apart okay so okay so here's what
I'm here's what I've noticed I've got
the four in my hand the two on the
outside are cut on the outside so that
it's clear how that happened the blade
just went into the outside two buns so
I'm going to tear those two off because
like that is obvious how that that
occurred and then I've toured that off
and now we've got okay in that one now
we've got these two ones on the inside
which are both of there now that the
outside buns are gone the outsides are
both the sealed sides so what we have is
in the middle and I'm sticking my finger
in them right now they have been cut by
a single blade that went right down the
middle of the four hot dog buns but was
not quite the width of the two hot dog
buns
so that blade went in the hot dog bun
butts and out the hot dog bun mouths and
and then if you open them you see that
this this slice has gone through both of
them and and that and
and all the way through so it they Oh
either it goes all the way through it's
not just like sliced on the inside it's
like the butt sliced too so the blade
the blade comes in
through the middle of the hotdog buns
and then you get four pre-sliced funds
and this one actually you can tell that
the blade went way further through one
of the buns than the other one because
it like this one is almost just two
pieces of bread and this one is really
secured together and now I have lots of
hot dog bun crumbs on my desk so well
Hank I cannot tell you how much I
appreciate you answering this question
in the form of a podcast where we can't
see any of the things that you're
talking about well you know what a hot
dog bun is it really adds to the
experience you know the situation like
you're not confused by what a hotdog bun
but is I'm not confused by what your
seat is we're on the same page you know
what our listeners are a lot smarter
than I am hopefully they'll be able to
follow what you just said my grandmother
patreon all right we'll post the diagram
on the patreon heggs gonna work up an
infographic to help you out there that's
patreon.com/lenguin
like we got another question comes from
Caroline who asks dear green brothers
what is the proper response to being
constantly serenaded see many members of
various musical acts have written a song
prominently featuring my name including
the Beach Boys Outkast Fleetwood Mac
Brooks & Dunn Chicago and of course Neil
Diamond while I love my name I've come
to expect a specific reaction to it is
there an optimal facial or verbal
response like frequently those
serenading me act like they are the
first to ever think of this idea well -
they struggle through the lyrics which
of course Caroline has memorized mine so
much when my good friends burst in to
Neil Diamond upon each side of me I
would mind that hello yes yes but with a
random store clerk here's your name and
breaks into song like it's the eighth
inning at Boston's Fenway Park what's a
person to do sweet comma Caroline great
sign off boy first of all I want to say
that last night laying in bed I googled
then indeed it's not touching and it's
oh god please stop reaching and like not
only is it you singing what you say you
wouldn't do any more
this this song sweet I'm sorry what was
the question my god
the Katherine hates the buff Papa's so
much she hates some silly to me it's not
even Sweet Caroline without the buzz
she's like don't pop pop ah there's
hordes they're doing it and why does
everybody say so good that's not even in
the Sun it's so good because the song is
so good I'm sorry what are we talking
about what was your answer
ma I was I was saying that I spent a
little time and I googled that indeed
like I didn't know Outkast had a song
about Caroline or that yeah Brooks &
Dunn did I don't know what Brooks & Dunn
was but there's a lot of songs about
Caroline's and that is a kind of
blessing but my guess is that all you
hear is Sweet Caroline you know I hear
we're like burst out into outcasts and
if you did you probably be like oh thank
the Lord for not singing Sweet Caroline
right now a little bit of variety in my
life is fantastic alright but but
there's something I think in particular
about Caroline where you immediately
that song stuck in your head because
it's somehow become so ingrained in
culture thanks I think largely to red
sox fans but no no it's not for Red Sox
fans I don't know man I just want to
point something out real quickly which
is that Caroline doesn't even mention
the best song about her name oh my god
which is the Old Crow Medicine Show song
Caroline which Sarah and I almost had as
our first dance at our wedding until we
realized that it is about a brother and
a sister but it is a great song is worth
looking up Caroline by Old Crow Medicine
Show a total winner for your name I do
think that this would be difficult most
blessings Hank are complicated blessings
and being named Caroline is certainly
one of them I think that I would just I
think that I would when it was a store
clerk or something I think I would just
say you know what I've I'm familiar with
that bit nope deeply disagree because
because you don't want to make some
stranger like
have a less good day oh just because
like they like then they're gonna be
like oh yeah I'm a freakin idiot nice
I'll take people so you're one of these
people who thinks like don't educate the
world one at a time just suffer a little
bit every day I mean yeah I guess if
you're going to the same store over and
over again like just stop and they like
sweet they serenade you every time stop
going there but yeah maybe you just
maybe just have a different name
sometimes I guess you got to give me a
great idea and they look if your ID in
there like uh Sweet Caroline hey girlie
oh no no no no you just go no you when
people look at your ID they're gonna see
like Caroline whatever your middle name
is do Busey yes I bet that's Caroline's
last name and and you could just be like
no I go by dubs I got a daughter because
that's that's how you shortened abuse II
I believe that'll be if that's how the
original des Busey's did it that's from
how they started going by dubs so I
would just that's what I would do
Caroline I would just like when you're
asked you know what's your name at
Starbucks just be like it's dubs yeah or
you can have like a pie no here's here's
the idea you have a button and that it
says I serenaded Sweet Caroline and then
every time somebody does it you just
give them a button that way great I do
not only is it fun for all but it costs
you extra money that's I think that's
the best idea so far keep a bunch of
buttons and say I serenaded Caroline de
Busey with Sweet Caroline and then maybe
have a couple that for the outcast song
just in case just in case just for roses
oh gosh there's a lot of it's not even
that particularly that good of a rhyme I
don't know why Caroline is such a great
great song - I think that I I think the
last syllable hits so hard and it feels
like the last syllable of Caroline has
always felt like a celebration to me
I've always been predisposed to
Caroline's by the way as you know Hank
there is something about that name that
has always rather captured me in the way
that the name Katherine captured Colin
singleton in my second novel
question comes from Brandon who writes
Dear John and Hank so a friend of mine
recently got his driver's license and
he's a great driver except for one thing
he's always nervous making left turns do
you remember that Hank yeah yeah yeah it
was terrifying when you first started
out so I'm curious how far can you get
making only right turns curious friend
Brandon John do you know that UPS takes
90% lovely to read this question so I
could share that UPS fact yeah
2012 it has stopped making left turns
they're like we're done with that that's
too much work well they figured out that
it was more fuel-efficient to make three
right turns not every time but most of
the time than it is to make one left
turn and so in certain big city
situations the GPS just says to make
three right turns
so I Brandon I think that that's no
problem I have no issue if your buddy
wants to treat the world like a UPS
driver and just review three rights
instead of one left just go around and
think well they also like you nice thing
about being a UPS driver is like you got
software that's planning your route for
you so you gotta go everywhere anyway so
there's got to be a way to get there by
making a bunch of right turns but they
do make a left turn sometimes but 90% of
the turns they make our right turns my
longtime mentor Eileen Cooper who you
know it's not a young person and has
probably been driving for I don't know
I'm gonna say 30 years so she doesn't
get mad at me Eileen has like never
makes a left turn she has a strict
policy that if she's going to have to
make a left turn in a drive then she's
just gonna take the train so if your
friend is not alone UPS drivers and
Eileen agree right turns of the way
forward
practice makes perfect John this next
question comes from Valerie who asks
dear Hank and John earlier this year I
got accepted to my first choice
university program at the far as the far
to the start of the fall as the start of
the fall semester gets nearer I think
that I'm going to start getting cold
feet so I guess my question is is it
normal to feel extremely unqualified
going into university I know that I got
into the program and that I earned my
place in the program but I can't shake
this feeling
hiding in the freezer to avoid summer
melt Valerie yeah I mean by the way
Valerie I think that feeling may
accompany you through the rest of your
life yeah just get used to this one it
has accompanied me through my entire
life where I have always felt like a
complete imposter and like I just don't
I am not qualified to be doing the
things that I'm doing and that at any
moment the world is going to figure that
out and the public shame that will
befall me will be unlike anything that
any human has ever experienced wow
that's that's well hopefully it's not
that bad
but John has a gift for hyperbole but
also for anxiety so who knows which one
it is
a little bit of mine is that woman who
made the extremely inappropriate tweet
about HIV infection in sub-saharan
Africa right before getting on an
airplane and by the time she landed
she'd been fired from her job and her
husband had divorced her and all of her
children had disowned her and she was a
pariah on the social Internet yeah I
think about that every time I write a
tweet and then I remind myself
okay well but this tweet isn't horrible
so like probably nothing bad is gonna
happen because I'm not saying something
that's like terrible and lamentable but
the truth is all of us make mistakes
Valerie and at any moment the public
could come for you and destroy your
reputation that is the question
I have a huge problem we're gonna get
back to you Valerie I promise but I have
a problem where like up if I post
something like even a little bit
controversial I have to check like five
minutes 15 minutes half an hour an hour
like to make sure that I didn't do
something super wrong or that I'm night
or that something that you wrote wasn't
taken right out of context or that it
wasn't hurtful in a way that you didn't
anticipate yes yeah and like that's
that's a lot of work for a freaking
tweet anyway I mean the the Internet has
become I think for most of us a place
that does not relieve anxiety
but yeah but back to Valerie's question
yeah I think it's it's really easy to be
anxious about something that you you
aren't doing yet the worst part for me
of anytime I'm gonna perform is sitting
backstage waiting to perform and that's
that's where you're at right now and
that's where a lot of people were at
until just now basically so it's very
likely that Valerie's at school now but
that that like not knowing how it's
going to be and imagining all the ways
that it could go wrong that is in part
like your brain preparing you for a new
experience but it's also like you can't
control it and so it's just unpleasant
focusing on like like achievable
objectives that are like okay well I'm
gonna go to school here's how like
here's something I can do to make myself
a better person in the meantime or or
like once you are there you're still
gonna be feeling this but in different
ways there's always this sort of like
the next thing that you're worrying
about but focusing on sort of like how
you are growing and how you have grown
and and giving a little bit of look back
at like how much more effective and
intelligent and knowledgeable you are
than you were you know four years ago
which is you know has been a probably a
pretty big time of change for you I'm
guessing if you're an incoming freshman
yeah or if you're anybody else really I
mean more years four years should
represent a significant amount of change
even to a forty year old man by the way
thanks for the birthday wishes Hank I'm
just kidding you didn't wish me a happy
birthday I called you on the phone and I
wished you I have a birthday I meant on
today's podcast I want birthday wishes
all month long happy birthday John I
know it was your birthday however long
ago that was forever ago okay I was
right about you old man a while ago Hank
I've got a question for you it comes
from Jackie and Josh you write Dear John
and Hank as we're sitting on our back
porch enjoying a fire on this chilly
August evening at 64 in the suburbs of
Chicago my fiancee Josh and I are
wondering does fire have mass it seems
to be weightless as you're watching it
is it even possible to measure the mass
of
something that's so volatile flaw me Oh
hot man Jackie and Josh is that that
does mean like catch on fire attractive
men I believe it does yeah I think
that's the technical latin flama yo hot
man it depends on what you mean like
there's a lot of conversations about
what fire is or like what's fire made of
and and that's like so there is in a way
fire is a chemical reaction and in that
way it doesn't have mass because it's
not really a thing it's an activity it's
like running doesn't have mass it just
is it it's a verb so in that way not
really but like fire is made up of
particles and those particles and energy
and both particles and energy have mass
or have mass equivalents so yeah I've
fire the stuff that you're seeing for
the most part is like glowing
smoke smoke that is so hot that it's
glowing and I leave for one way or
another for one reason or another and
it's complicated the recent writers like
pythons giving live birth I'm pretty
sure they'll never rush I can't trust
you ever again I'm pretty sure this is
right that like there's little particles
of smoke and they are so hot and they
are so energized that they're producing
light in various ways and the ways in
which they are producing later I think
pretty complicated but I don't know but
they are particles and so those things
and and currently why they're going
upward is because they are surrounded by
very hot gas that has been heated up in
the fire and that gas is moving upward
and it's carrying those particles with
it and as cold air sort of rushes into
the fire that that hot air is hotter and
it's less dense and so it's moving up
because colder more dense airs being
pushed underneath it so gravity is the
reason why fire goes up and in when
there's no gravity fire doesn't go up
and you can actually see videos of fire
on the space station and it forms a
sphere which is weird
the comes like a dangerous game you
light a fire on the space station they
control it pretty well they have little
higher loss oh hey Hank slightly
of topic did you know that you can
actually eat by Python eggs the eggs
that you didn't think existed they're
about twice the size of a chicken egg
and more yolk in proportion to white
than a chicken egg does and a stronger
richer taste but other than that there's
not much difference people love eating
Python eggs I'm looking at some Python
egg recipes right now
Wow I mean how often do pythons lay eggs
and can you just farm pythons for eggs
you're not you don't know the answer
well no as far as I can tell Hank people
only raise pythons to eventually release
them into the Everglades
to create a non-native invasive species
that can go to war with alligators
that's my understanding that's good this
one comes from the siblings crow well
who write Dear John and Hank recently my
sister and I went to our local hipster
mall what I'm sorry there's a hipster
mall what do you shop for hipsters yeah
I'm surprised to learn that there is
such a thing as a hipster mall the malls
near me still all have Spencer Gifts
inside of them to our local hipster mall
to catch a screening of Rushmore even
more surprised
Wow yeah both of us have been longtime
listeners at the pod and we both thought
the recommendation of the film was too
great to pass up we enjoyed the film
thoroughly but found ourselves in
profound anticipation of the quote I
ain't even here sergeant I'm in Cheyenne
Wyoming much to our surprise it wasn't
even a quintessential instance in the
movie as a whole while we have since
made peace with being misled with what
we thought was the most iconic quote in
Rushmore how could one make peace with
being misled by those we look up to jake
Ivalo stay facendo
the siblings crow well I hope you guys
didn't just make me curse in Latin uh
how did you mislead people you said
there was a quote in a movie and the
movie to me the whole thing that makes
Rushmore great is that many of the best
lines are not presented with like and
now we will cut the music so that the
character can say a line and then like
CSI Miami style put their sunglasses on
like I love I love that there are so
many great little lines in that movie
that you might not even notice till your
second or third viewing I
apologize if I made it seem like it's a
like a critical moment in the movie it's
not like it's it's a play within a play
moment and but I just I love that line I
love that line
so I I can't really apologize because
I'm not really sorry because I think
that's what makes Rushmore so great but
it does have some other great lines for
sure and don't worry the next time that
I'm working on a book I'm sure that I
will quote all of them to Hank while we
are potting I really need to watch this
Rushmore movie John I assume that it is
about the president's murder mystery oh
my god oh my god how how good okay so
there's the most amazing thing in the
movie I think I've even told you this
before the most amazing thing in the
movie happens very early on where the
Bill Murray character says to Max Fisher
what's the secret Max and Max says the
secret and Blum says yeah you seem to
have it pretty figured out and Max says
the secret I don't know I guess you've
just got to find something you love to
do and then do it for the rest of your
life for me it's going to Rushmore I'd
like the idea that like Max Fisher has
figured out his passion but it's going
to this one particular high school it's
just perfect
okay that does sound good that does
sound good I would like to have a
passion I have many I would like to have
a particular passion
oh my god what I wouldn't give for Hank
to have one passion what would that even
be like I sometimes I see like people
who just tweet about one thing and I'm
like yeah you person who loves this one
particular weather satellite how do I
just I wonder if those people in real
life though like on a day-to-day basis
if they're always thinking about that
one particular weather satellite or
weather satellites in general or if like
they also have lots of other interests
they don't share those interests with
the public eye I would like for you to
have one driving public facing interest
so that I wouldn't have to have so many
jobs being the tail
you're mini-comics kebaya could my like
one public-facing interest just be going
on Jamaican holiday no god that's so
obviously the phrase good no no no
everyone knew everyone knew even close
everybody forgot there was even a phrase
of the week they didn't even know that
was the phrase the week is if they don't
forgot that there is a phrase of the
week bit that we're doing for a little
bit to see if it works which it probably
isn't we had it we had a phrase of the
week which is Jamaican holiday but Hank
wedged it in there with all of the
subtlety of like Donald Trump getting
eight tenths of the way through a speech
and realizing hasn't said anything about
building the wall I felt good about it I
felt no III think that it's a definite
loss I think it's a definite win for me
but that said today's podcast is brought
to you by Jamaican holidays Jamaican
holidays I actually don't think Hank has
ever been on one but Sarah and I go on
one every year oh oh hi I didn't I
didn't know that today's podcast is also
brought to you by hot dog bun butts get
yourself a four pack put your finger
right down in the middle and say that's
that's how they do it hot dog bun butts
and today's podcast has additionally
brought to you by the sphere of fire on
the international space station yet one
more reason not to be an astronaut and
finally this podcast is brought to you
by Python eggs hot fresh and tasty
available at your local Python egg
eatery special for your favorite
Jamaican holidays hey we do have a real
sponsor today it's fracture fracture
which people can check out at fracture
me.com slash podcast it is a really cool
service so Mike I have all of these
pictures on my phone right and then I
have all of these pictures from when I
was a child that are just physical
pictures but the pictures that are
inside of my phone I can't really do
anything with them very effectively
because they're inside of my phone
fracture sort of solves that problem
both of those problems really by
printing photos onto glass and they come
it's really cool they come
with this backing and they come with the
screw so you just screw it into the wall
you place it on to the wall and there is
your family photo or your photo of your
car that only makes right-hand turns or
whatever it is I actually got some
fracture prints that that have not
arrived yet after they arrive we'll
probably do another one of these for
fracture but I have I have gotten my
fracture prints and I have to say they
are really really cool so we have a
little wall in our house where we have
family pictures and you know other stuff
like pictures of great-grandparents and
whatnot and they are they look really
good there so they've they've become
part of our collection of family photos
was it what did you what did you end up
in our base did you get printed oh just
pictures of the kids you know now I got
me Mars mostly are you serious well I
got to of Mars I got one of Horan you
could have gotten a picture made of
anything from fracture and you pick oh I
know what's that Hank you found your one
passion it goes all the way back to your
Mars exploration website when you were
14 it's not your family it's not making
online videos it's not podding it's
freaking Mars well I thought maybe you
get like at least one one of while
Taylor or something oh that would have
been cool I didn't think of that but
yeah you can go to fracture me calm sigh
podcast now and get a Lyell Taylor
picture ready to put on your wall that
works especially well if you are Lyle
Taylor I know he's a big fan of the pod
yeah and also if you're not and I mean
the they come in a huge variety of sizes
and the smallest smaller ones are pretty
cheap like you don't have to lay down a
bunch of cash on this right and then it
goes all the way up to like really huge
and more expensive ones the the nice
thing about like these smaller ones is
like it can go sort of straight like you
could actually log in with your
Instagram and have all your Instagram
photos there and be like I just want
these like six Instagram photos and then
you can sort of space them out on your
wall so that they take up a large area
without costing a bunch of money yeah I
have to say Rosie Anna did that she just
did the ones directly from Instagram and
then had them printed and I was
astonished genuinely by
the quality of the picture that
eventually came so yeah I was really
impressed by by fracture and you can
check it out at fracture me comm /
podcast and when you're there there's a
little survey that you fill out and you
tell them that you heard about it here
on dear Hank and John and then they also
say that you heard about it on Dear John
and Hank and that will confuse them so
there's just that one podcast blink it
says dear Hank John because we haven't
changed the name of the podcast though
that's looking increasingly likely that
we eventually will in 2028 fracture me
calm slash podcast
alright Nick let's get back to questions
from our listeners this one comes from
Laura and I think you're gonna love it
Hank because it gets into something deep
ominous dark and deadly Dear John and
Hank here's the thing so a mermaid is
half fish and half human right
what do mermaids eat I know that fish
often eat other fish and that's
completely acceptable but as someone who
is half fish and half human with the
thinking and feeling human part of a
mermaid feel cannibalistic eating a fish
if a mermaid does feel cannibalistic
eating fish and assuming they have fish
friends like Ariel does and Little
Mermaid then would said mermaid be
disgusted at their fish friends for
eating fish
additionally would a mermaid be able to
survive get enough protein etc on a
vegetarian type diet with what they have
available in the ocean do you think that
a mermaid considers shellfish such as
clams and mussels to be part of her own
species or distinguishes these as edible
food sources without guilt Hank there
are many good questions within this
question to unpack but to me the
critical one is do we make a distinction
between species and like order or class
or genus when it comes to cannibalism in
short Hank was it cannibalism for humans
of the homo sapien species to eat
Neanderthals of the other human species
is that cannibalism if you eat a
different species of humans because
Neanderthals and Homo sapiens did
coexist what would it have been
cannibalism to eat them I mean so I'm
answering this this question but I
before I do I gotta say that fish are
not as closely related as we are with
Neanderthals like there are lots of fish
that are much more distantly related
than that so there are a lot of fish
especially when you talk about shellfish
which aren't even fish
they're malas right that's a totally
different thing but anyway but like kind
of clown fish eat a parrotfish or are
they too tight well I don't think either
those fish eat eat fish but well
hypothetically Hank hypothetically I
could on fish yeah
like can I can I can a shark eat a shark
can like a can a great white shark eat a
hammerhead shark and be like no big and
I think yes I think absolutely yes no
big but all right so panic can a member
of the Homo sapiens species right eat a
member of the Neanderthal species and
not have it be cannibalism I think it's
not cannibalism but I still think it's
really wrong mostly it definitely
happened cannibalism was super common
for almost all of human history oh yeah
yeah yeah no I I I think you think it's
wrong I think mostly the killing is
wrong like if you come across a dead
Neanderthal I don't know it gives me the
willies that's for sure yeah I've got
the wheels yeah I don't think it's wrong
Laura I think that you can eat whatever
you want to eat as long as you don't
kill it and if you're gonna eat
something that did get killed in order
for you to eat it then you should be
emotionally and morally ready to have
killed that thing that's basically what
I think but I will say that I think I
wouldn't be a problem for a mermaid to
be a vegetarian like I think that they
can pull that off
oh there's so much seaweed and the
seaweed is very it's high in protein
it's got seaweeds got everything in it
yeah it's good stuff got kelp but III do
a little worried about like how do you
cook underwater because that is sushi if
you're a bi mermaid cuz you like and
everybody likes sushi but nobody wants
sushi all the time no just take it down
to one of those deep-sea vents where
it's hot and weird and cooking its hold
it over the vent I mean this is a very
adventurous hypothetical mermaid that
we've got I mean the good news is that
there are no mermaids
wait god I I'll tell you what if my
daughter does listen to this she's gonna
be devastated alice is so funny she the
only things that she believes in are
leprechauns which she believes are real
in Ireland
matter how many times I tell her that
they are made up and that they are
definitely not real but she'll be like
dragons were never real daddy and I'll
be like that's right and she'll be like
unicorns are not real and I'm like
that's right Alice and she'll be like
but leprechauns are real and I'm like no
they are and she's like they are in
Ireland and I'm like no they're not in
Ireland they're not real anywhere and
then she'll say and mermaids are real
and I'll be like yeah and she'll be like
but very rare well what are we to tell
her different I mean I don't even know
where some point we're gonna come from
did you ever go to that episode of this
American life where the poor kid whose
parents had never quite broken the news
about unicorns was at a college party
and they were just kissing endangered
animals and the effects that humans have
had on on Biological Diversity and she
asked are unicorns extinct or just
endangered maybe the best advice that we
can give that young person who's headed
off to college is that unicorns were
never real so now you're totally ready
for your first year of university yeah
well about also we hit we have a is
there like a special label on iTunes for
like like Alice can't listen to this one
yeah it's like it's just an a no Alice
Hank before we get to the news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon we have a couple more
things to mention most importantly we
need to give you I need to give you an
update you might remember Clara remember
yeah yeah Clara who lost her vitally
important shared journal on the
Greyhound bus mm-hmm Clara whose name I
was convinced was Clara I misread the
question her name was Cara so first of
all guys - Clara secondly she wrote in
to say Dear John a Nick thank you so
much for answering my question I was
ecstatic when I heard it I wanted to let
you know that we found the locus also I
wanted to let you know that John's
advice was helpful because I found it in
my room
come on Oh glory you got a look at your
room before you called greyhound or dear
Hank job no that's the but definitely
definitely contact your friendly local
advice podcast before you call anybody
else we also got some nail specific sign
offs that I want to read hang yeah we
got a great one from cat who signs her
emails off curiosity hasn't killed me
yet cat we got a great one from Tyson
who signs off his emails of Tyson men I
really like the fun from Mary who signs
off eat drink and be merry oh it's great
great because it's got works both ways
and someone wrote in that their mother
has an amazingly British name specific
sign off the crown comma jewels I also
want to thank Alex for sending in a
couple of suggestions for my daughter
Alice when she's old enough to be
writing emails I very much like this
sign off with love or malice this one's
from Alice
goodgoodgood not allowed at the Vatican
Palace Alice what did we also gonna be
true
Hank is there any way that I could go
first because I have incredible news I
have the most exciting news that you
could possibly imagine
did you score a point we scored Hank in
the last two games AFC Wimbledon scored
wait for it
six goals goals are possible they were
two staples are us after scoring one
goal in the first three games of the
season
just kidding first four games of the
season and no goals in the previous like
six games of last season AFC Wimbledon
scored two goals against Doncaster
Rovers to win their first league game
before that someone on Twitter had sent
me a very mean message what's the
difference between ASD Wimbledon and a
triangle a triangle has three points and
that was very mean and I just want to
say that that was me but you know what
now AFC Wimbledon has four points for
league points take it's pretty much all
you need to stay up
a critical win against Doncaster Rovers
and and I'm really excited about it it
means that AFC Wimbledon are now well
out of the relegation places by one
point and yeah right what do we need to
be four points after four games and then
last night as we're recording this
the Dons played in the all-important
checkatrade Football League trophy which
is one of these like you know it's one
of the like Cup games that isn't about
the league it's like a different
competition where all the teams in
England play each other and AFC
Wimbledon started a team that can only
be described as pretty much all children
aha in many cases some literal children
played but they played very very well
they scored four goals and one for three
score goal scorers include included
eglee kasha ant hardigan who is 17 years
old and just signed a professional
contract and Cody McDonald so very
exciting to see the young players from
Wimbledon get a chance to play and to
play so well 4-3 victory to nil victory
to goal to wins on the trot the Dons are
going up Hank next season the
championship all right uh or this season
you you just got to win more yeah we
just have to win a lot yeah go what's it
got a whole lot John you know what a big
problem about going to Mars is who is it
that the fuel weighs so much and you
need to like extra fuel to pay it'sit's
to push the fuel that weighs so much
that is one of the big ones but but a
lesser-known one is that omega-3 fatty
acids are essential essential oils not
in the knot of the meaning of essential
oil that you have heard of but but
essential meaning that we can't make
them ourselves but our body needs them
so we have to go through them and they
actually break down over time they are
not stable and if you if you try to if
you try to just put them in a pill
eventually they turn into other stuff
and so basically the scientists say like
we need to bring something with us that
can make these things
yeah and also in general when you're
going to Mars you want to save every
atom and turn it into something useful
and so that means light like when you're
peeing like that B you're gonna take all
the water out of it and you're gonna
drink that water again but then you're
gonna be left with some other stuff a
lot of urea for example you want to use
that you want to turn it into something
useful
well some new research it's taken that
urea and and combining it with carbon
dioxide which is you know we exhale it
but it's also there's lots of it on Mars
and and and a yeast as well as a
cyanobacteria which altogether can turn
urea and carbon dioxide into two
different things one omega-3 fatty acids
which you could them out and be like
this is delicious and I sprinkled it on
my toast this morning we're spread it on
my toast I guess and the other like
basically polyester so that you could
use that too you know it's just a
plastic that you can use in like a 3d
printer to turn into you know whatever
the 3d printer needs to make so this
research was presented by Clemson
University's Mark Berliner associate
professor of chemical and biomolecular
engineering and the the hope is that in
the future because right now I could
sort of I'll get slight like tied up
inside of the yeast I decided this
little fungi
I wouldn't sell fun fun to I think that
not only will we be able to sort of like
get those yeasts to leave it behind in
some way that we can get it without
having to kill them but also that we
could potentially
engineer them to be making very specific
molecules and that would allow us to
create better plastics that would be
more useful and also better stuff for
eating
so yeah although we needed some of that
some of the nitrogen urea to help make
the some of those things and great and
now we got now that's happening so yeah
you can watch a video about it that's on
the co I know it it's produced by PBS
Digital Studios on the industry I don't
there's a pictures of like you know
you're insane
full vials there's no one PA oh boy oh
boy
I mean that is like nothing has ever
made me want to not go to Mars quite
like knowing that I'm gonna get my
omega-3 fatty acids from the part of my
pee that I'm not drinking that on the
International Space Station the US side
of the space station has a urine
recycler and so they take the urine and
they go through a whole process and then
they drink it but on the Russia side of
the space station they don't have one of
those so what do you think they do do
they just shoot it out into space no
John they put it in a giant bag and they
bring it over to the US side of the
space station and put it in the machine
oh man
space the final frontier in so many ways
oh space well what are we gonna do with
all this pee Hank what did we learn
today
John we learned that mama Python and
hatchling do kiss waggling round and you
shouldn't burn books and we also learned
that hot dog buns have butts that get
cut somehow
we learned that ups takes 90% right-hand
turns and that high lean Cooper takes 0%
right turn hand turns because she'll
just take the train thank you very much
left-hand turns
she doesn't take any left in terms to be
clear that's very calming and lastly we
learned that Hank
does not have one passion but it would
be nice for his brother if he did yeah
Hank thank you for potting with me we're
off now to record this week in Ryan's
our special podcast that we do every
week where we talk about Orion whoo
lately hasn't been named Ryan over at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John you
can find out more over there if you want
to join in on this weekend Ryan's the
worst eight minutes of your week this
podcast sponsored by fracture fracture
me calm slash podcast where you can
click on us and then make your make your
beautiful pictures into actual physical
things that you can put on your wall
dear Hank and John is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and sheridan Gibson
our community manager
is viktoria buongiorno it's edited by
Nicholas chickens our music is by the
grid gunnarolla you can email us at Hank
and John at gmail.com you can find us on
Twitter Hank green and John Green easy
enough and as they say in our hometown
don't forget to be on
[Music]